this star was filming so amazing scare
my beard off it's coming back but we did
see solo as the person who gave him his
name said it that that I always loved
that movies when they do this won't we
have to call you something
Hana solo looks a lot of bad in this
they just call it solo a star war is
something that exists that was pretty
much my entire feeling I'm like this
this exists come on
this was the first I'm excited because
this was the first Star Wars film I
wasn't excited to see I have like no
thought going into X I take you back and
take the clones I wanna see but honestly
I remember right I don't think I had any
thoughts one way or another going into
broke was very curious about ro Guam I
was just hoping it would be good and I
liked a movie better than I did this I
yeah I think I like that better too cuz
that at least that obviously had issues
but I got better and better this is kind
of reversed for me I actually thought I
started off okay I like kind of a world
war one stuff and I like when he has a
purpose he's trying to get back
somewhere and stuff and that just kind
of gets dollar and dollar and don't see
I had the opposite problem I thought it
it peaked somewhere in the middle and
the second half over all I probably
found better but the first part was like
with them throwing all that stuff in
there I mean just the first part now we
have to do this thing now we had now and
I'm just like the first part just just
almost from the start some about this
movie like just annoyed me something it
didn't annoy me and I made the call bag
I didn't I didn't hate it
no no I grow myself to say I hated that
would have probably required more
emotional investment and I mean it it
just it just little it's it's just like
death by a thousand paper cuts I was
just mildly annoyed the whole way it
didn't help like full disclosure I'm
like under the weather today and I've
had like a low-grade migraine all day so
I don't think that was helping
but I feel like even if I was like you
know not just like yeah like I still
probably would have been like man okay
so this movie when we saw it handsome
people you know applauding and cheering
with certain people showed up and at the
end there's an applause - I feel like as
a generic action Star Wars film it's
fine can we can we like okay we're
talking about applauding can we be
honest here and say like two of those
applauses were just the albumen Kotori
the movie started and ended applauses
like literally the first applause in
this movie was it says a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away my favorite is
that one guy there's always one guy
who's always trying to start the
applause and sometimes once you know and
then there's one word just didn't work
at all this one the Millennium Falcon
pop that guy's like because you know
everyone's like no we're done cause I
remembers when the Millennium Falcon
showed up and yeah a few people did
applaud maybe a think of another one
there was one where somebody tried to
applaud it that just nobody did okay no
that was somewhere else the Falcon got
an actual applause but I I turned to my
wife and I said this is kind of telling
when the only legit applause we've had
has been for the ship hmm like that's
the only loud applause I remember that
wasn't the beginning and ending of the
film like I think of the other Star Wars
films I think of spider-man or infinity
war or a lot of Marvel movies like if
there's an applause like you get a few
of them this this one was definitely is
just like it was just the Falcon the
Falcon shows up he's like yeah and then
that was kind of it and then and then
like at the end like but we knew that
was the end of the film anyway so people
were applauding like there was a there
was a very confused applause first way
oh really
anyone that's seen the movie already
knows I can't hear the internet talk
this one a few times I'm acting like
okay I I want I fear that is saying
about this character about to call Alex
and an axe from Tim burns baman I can't
wait to hear the explanation the best
one great guys well we'll get to that so
oh my big thing with this movie is that
there's no big thing in it no okay okay
so you got the do playing han solo III
from the trailers he didn't seem that
interesting B I actually thought he did
a pretty good job there's a lot of times
where I thought he really captured
Harrison Ford very welcome he's a
two-faced like 50% of the time I think
it's like kind of creepy I'm just like
oh yeah he is like Han Solo there and
the other 50% of the time I'm like what
are you doing it's like a guy it's like
one of those like it's like somebody
doing an accent in a movie only they
don't quite nail it so there are times
where you're just like wow nailed it and
then the next sentence you're like wait
what like and he was kind of like that
like I I really bought him in some
scenes and other times I'm just like I I
don't know who I'm looking at now I like
every salad especially with the script
he's given this is this is not this is
not a good script at all your lines like
there's a scene where like Woody
Harrelson is shooting the gun the
Millennium Falcon and the gun gets
blasts away goes oh you know and they're
really a joke it's like I lost the
cannon and I hurt my thumbs
it's like like they're trying to make
this a suspenseful scene it's like
that's just my face like it's like a
couple just or so well but his love
interest is the smiling like something
something smiles no and there's a nurse
and I was like what the hell like who
wrote this and no then at the end
credits I see it's like not one cast an
but to cast ends and I'm like wow
finally happened they wrote a bad start
well and then I don't care what you say
about force awakens that was still a
better script
yeah they had like some good lines and
everybody had some clever stuff now and
then there's a scene at the end where
you know she's like I know what you
really are
at first away first scoundrel I didn't
she doesn't say that to their cut but
she's like a good guy he's like well no
no I'm not a good guy and I'm thinking
myself this is even a debate in this way
it be cool if that was like a thing and
oh no there's no wires there's a little
no-tell han that knows no meat to that
character this movie you know which it's
oh yeah we love Hans yellow as a
character if you want to see him as a
smuggler I want to see him as a bad guy
once him do some dirty nasty ass you
know stop the people and backstab and
then maybe find there's a living like
maybe that's what they're gonna do with
the sequel that they're obviously trying
to set up but yeah I have never been
this disappointed in Han probably since
like Jedi when he suddenly becomes like
oh hey it's me like it's like you
because like he was badass in Episode
four he was still he gets frozen in
carbonite at Empire and he's still
badass there and then like somewhere in
Jedi like George Lucas took over again
and now he's like he's breaking sticks
and he's screwing up everywhere and he's
doesn't know he has such hot hate for
him and generally I don't hate him in
Jedi but it definitely took a character
that was cool and then he's like getting
felt up by he walks and it's like what
that's great him this is but but this is
what it feels like I'm just like I think
did it again they some I'm like this
should be him it is badass
like his Mosby yeah there she is
badassery and instead it's just a sory
and so you got is so but but the actor I
thought was good I like to have loved
her as Lana no we really he was such a
shit damn thing in the movie he
should've been just a lego movie why
didn't they do yeah and what do I need
to know about Han Solo we've had one two
three obviously not much or yeah
for films now with Han Solo like if
there's a character I ever wanted to
know more about its Lando because he
just they show up on Cloud City he's
like I've got some problems of my own
here and I sold you out to the Empire
I'm now I'm gonna help you and now I'm
gonna book this will you get going you
pirate and it's fine but I'm just like I
I'm just like I would like to know more
about yeah because we're less time with
it so those two and I'll give credit
actually like Chewie
I mean I guess I never disliked
Chewbacca but it's one of those things
I'm just like yeah I don't know I I
really dug him in this movie i I can't
dug him no you're like well we'll get
into them spoiler yeah but we push this
out man big bad boy yeah I know but and
then like the robot the droid and three
I thought was okay uh does bring up a
good point of that I never thought about
before it's like yeah how art what is
the like the freedom or the civil rights
or whatever of droids like it never
really to the spit like cuz I we don't
serve your time there no so they should
like be making shit no way like since
yes it started there but if you read
like the extended universe or even like
you know play some of the the games back
of the day even in the 90s they were
talking about that that that was like a
thing that the Empire has like an or the
the huts or the syndicates or whatever
are all into droid abuse like this has
always been some sort of like theme
within Star Wars ever second classes I
know there's probably gonna be people
freaking I they might that's been there
since the beginning nobody never thought
about it's just one of those things
where I'm like well wait that this is a
good but like are they just is it just
like a computer that turns on the light
or something or is it like yeah cuz of
these things have AI names I I never
thought about how it worked in this
universe because you know and people
with British accents and southern accent
in a galaxy far far away I don't know
how the shit this works it's such a
fantasy but it's one of those things
okay yeah you're right that that is
something that's here is technically
always when I think there was
intentional or when I played x-wing on
the PC they had like this instruction II
knew that came with it was like the
Empire's many crimes and one of them was
like droid abuse okay
like but yeah so yeah so she's good
she's got this whole thing
what did you say bot lives matter yeah I
came by to go hashtag me to detune she's
she's all into the like via the
liberation of the bots which I I don't
know I thought she was one of the better
characters in it because she had a
freaking personality yeah but like I
said so it's like I like and and some of
the cool things like I said I like
seeing surprising I like seeing how
semister bad like seeing how he met
Chewie I like seeing him make the Kessel
run
I like seeing how they didn't like it I
guess so
well wait too long sock but no but I let
you know and as you saw is how he did it
that's kind of cool yeah no that's fine
if they want to show you how they did it
then how about this how much you fucking
show us something no no okay not leading
up to the Kessel run actually but he
when he got out of it Kessel run that's
what I like yeah okay getting on oh so
nice oh the Kessel run itself
yeah it looks like a net smoke yeah if
you like looking at a lot of smoke
there's your Kessel run it is like this
this whole movie what I'm sorry like can
we finally just say that Ron Howard is
not a great director like it's a figure
eight it's getting to a point though
where I'm like I don't care if you did
frost/nixon or Apollo 13 like it's
really bugging me now whenever I sit
through another bland ass Ron Howard fit
up Rob I care Star Wars movie Ron power
together with them um it seemed like
this is like one of them you know I this
is one of the blandest looking stiff not
the blandest looking Star Wars movie
ever made
okay well I'll give credits down the
bland of Star Wars thing I've ever seen
the prequels are good but they look more
interesting in us it didn't look like
Star Wars but it look nice then that
pisses me like that lived that may be
the only thing in this movie like I said
I didn't hate it but that may be the one
thing that legitimately pisses me the
hell off I'll give a little nervous like
this no I'll give credit to the
cinematography because I feel like these
designs are not
these are very bland boring smoky hard
to see you know just grated designs but
a lot of the times I thought the
mountains were shot nice I thought like
okay so like that Kessel run thing it's
just the smoke circling it's like
nothing but when you see like the
Imperial ship coming through the way
that sound the way it's frame I thought
look pretty cool the cinematography is
has like 30 40 percent really great
shots of like mountain stuff but it's
nothing that we haven't seen a thousand
times before they all look like Lord of
the Rings shots
here's same mountains again here's some
more mountains you know but I'd say 60%
of the cinematography this one was
terrible
no because I do not know and the act
like Oh your feet you don't know they
had it's incomprehensible
no there's times where you have to go
like when he sees land oh you know and
that that's the dark brown again we've
seen that all over but for that scene
that's the kind of shots that yeah and
there's like - yeah there's ten models
right there and then some ways they're
just odd and weird I I think there's
also great callbacks - you know a lot of
classic cinema like classic Westerns
what's the Tony Curtis movie where he's
chained together guy and stuff like
there's definitely callbacks to that I
think there's a lot of stuff going on is
kind of that's a really good callback I
thought they weren't I thought for fat
units of the way one guy whole bands I
thought were really really cool I think
there's a lot of stuff in here that
actually you can put motherfuck
motherfuckas a lot of Star Wars films
but we could tell just it was warm one
that's what they were going for so no
but I'm saying that's good you could
tell that an Empire Strikes Back
I'm still shot better pabelln because
it was shot that's why after this what's
it like I do sir I think it's designed
poorly I I do think it's designed very
there there are some shots that are good
like when they go make sure they go to
the big bad guy the big bad gangster who
at first was kind of cool and then he
gets dull by the end but it's like yeah
it's like that casino again from the
last hours from uh last Jedi it's like
we just saw it this damn place it was
boring there and it's boring now you
know where you just go up there and
there's black and white and yellow and
people serving tray and and that was
boring and budget
in an outfit yeah visions not a very
yeah it's visions like the villain I
guess like I guess yeah something keeps
change he's not and he's not an
interesting put some tiger stripes on
his face they're like I know at first I
felt like okay this guy might be cool
and then again they don't really do
anything with him he just kind of be
good and okay again we won't give
anything to too much away but cuz the
spoiler corners for a lot of it it's not
really spoiling much because because you
can don't trust that person guess what
you were supposed to trust that person
you know you shouldn't trust me guess
what you weren't supposed to trust you
know there's a lot of double-crossers at
triple cross eight guess what that
person's gonna double cross that person
get a triple crab and it's like call it
spell it all like from the beginning so
they try to throw in a red herring just
to make you forget but no I called it
from the beginning everything if
everything you think is gonna happen
happens okay so what should we should
like when when Chewie shows up it's
looks like they make it mysterious like
what's is gonna be a Mike it's chewing
yeah like every single scene is like
that it is so predictable and there's a
lack there so there's something to say
about this wrote one yeah well I would
refer we're gonna get the death star
players like there's no suspense we had
no idea who was really gonna live or die
though this I'm just like there is a
certain boredom that sets in for some of
these scenes cuz like my wife turns me
it's like you think Chu he's gonna make
it like and I'm like I completely agree
with her I'm just like yeah I'm there's
no suspense because we know Chewie Han
and Lando at least have to make in then
that's three of your more interesting
kind a lot of times they're together
with the other characters just instantly
like the second they pop up who's not
gonna make it it's fucked
well yeah the side characters are not
that interest with the exception of the
robot but yeah not the psychic Rio
character played by Jon Favreau
I was actually kind of I be okay we
shouldn't give it away but I was like
yeah I was enjoyable and he was annoying
I ya know he was me dude there's just
something about I was like this voice is
not coming out of this creature
something he does not match this is like
Sean Connery and dragonar I'm like
something doesn't seem right about
this what if they could make him fight
that a lot of these lines aren't that
funny yeah I mean that's what's kind of
weird like you think there'd be you know
in Disney's been doing really good with
like Marvel and Star Wars and stuff and
having maybe it's good comedy maybe cast
ends aren't as iron ferrule in one and
then there's all the production problems
like you know the the lego movie team
was supposed to be behind this and then
they got canned and I start to wonder
I'm like what scenes were theirs with it
actual scenes that made me laugh there's
or were some of the scenes I didn't like
there's or was that all I know is this
is bland and that to me says Ron Howard
here here's the biggest problem to me my
number one problem with this movie and
why I don't think it's interesting think
hond is interesting they start out from
the very beginning setting him up he
he's from like you know there's a poor
neighborhood he really under and stuff
like that heroic and he's trying to get
out and again without giving away too
much he has he gets out but he wants to
come back here there's a reason he wants
to come back and it's be years later and
he wants to come back why you won't go
back there I want to go back there for
this reason he keeps talking about this
reason like at the end of the first act
the reason comes to him and it's like oh
okay
you know how this movie yeah but but a
place just that's like okay I'll give
credit and see that coming but but now
what that seemed to be like your big
emotional art and the movie it's like
well now we got to do this thing okay
they're gonna do this thing well okay
that's done now well now we got to do
that thing well okay I mean at some
point I was saying why should I give a
shit that he's doing all since this is
ours because it's just trying to be an
origin story and yet it has no origin
story for its care yeah because I'm just
like maybe we should have started off
with him as a legit kid like some
frickin street rat instead he's already
looks like he's 25 like Mike if this was
a fast and furious movie just with Han
Solo in a Star Wars you probably would
have liked it better totally cool with
that I want to see him steal shit I
wanna see him Robbie I want to see a
punch people I want to see in
smooth-talker sway us unless you talk to
Jabba there's no job in this movie it's
like the one cameo agency made me and
Jerry
[Music]
but no that's like the one thing I
really wanted to see I wanted to see him
talk to Jap I wanted to see him get in
these situations and like smooth talkers
way out I want
I wonder we done
no just crimson John yeah no it's like
no no well now we stole that well now
there's these other people they're going
through shit that you know now we had to
fight for them and now these people are
gonna end it now there's this big
rebellion and I believe in myself
okay there's energy here and there's
action and some of it's doing well but
am I not caring and I rely there's no
system there's no way there's no
motional arc and then random things like
oh he's gonna I mean we all know this
it's in the trailer he's gonna make a
bet with Lando and play a card game and
they're all like I don't think you
should do this I got this trust me as if
we're supposed to know something like
about Oh like Hans not good at gambling
or no it's ok Hans secretly good again
we've seen no scenes with him gambling
do you realize that yeah there is like
nothing in that scene that works except
for the fact that we know eventually
what's gonna happen but I'm just like
well so what are we supposed to take out
of this cuz she's nervous
you know Beckett's just like I don't
know and Lando's I'm just like we've we
don't know what exactly his baseline is
we've never seen him gamble had they had
one scene earlier or maybe if his first
scene was him losing badly at a gambling
game hmm or or being a gambling shark or
doing something like in his first scene
like maybe then I'd be like okay like
now we know that they have a right to be
nervous or maybe they don't need to be
nervous but it's just they play it up
like we're supposed to know something
and we don't know jack-shit we know
nothing about this guy except what what
the frickin long time ago in a galaxy
far far away font told us so instead of
doing the opening crawl now now they
just have the blue text do you guys got
change I get every move either what
every Star Wars story you know they're
gonna have something different I know
it's just kind of that's another little
thing like that it's not a movie record
but I just keep the damn crawl vague mmm
yeah and this one's calendaring that too
it's like well okay what have been sure
but I mean it's
I mean if you're still using text to
sense the baby yeah it's a bit like I
played plenty of Star Wars games and
nobody like it was very simple they
would just call it by the title like you
know Star Wars Rogue Squadron Star Wars
TIE fighters any of the mission Star
Wars Imperial pursuit whatever you
didn't have to put the episode title the
idea was the episode titles are the big
movies and then these others are side
stories it's like we can't confuse them
and we need the big like Solo logo to
like flash in a hologram over the sights
of Karelia like and I'm just like that
was another thing that it just didn't
feel like the whole movie didn't feel
strangely enough like a Star Wars movie
to me what one did I what do you like
what one a night I'm like good if you
don't like that's the universe but the
opening this I felt like if you didn't
have the hover cars I'm just like this
feels almost like baby driver or
something it's like some some punk kid
driving around in a car trying to get
away from something with all these kind
of semi mood lighting and I was ok with
that I was ok with kind of the dark
gritty dirty you know because again
you're kind of setting him up and then
he goes in to warn it looks like war and
it feels like war and I kind of like I'm
like okay I like this background I like
how he meets Chewie nothing I like the
direction was going but as soon as the
reason he wanted to get back to that
planet comes to him I'm just like well
now why do I care about this dude
and even the connection between him and
the reason is not that good I mean that
there is not much of a guy living as it
finally started at least turning into
some sort of Han Solo ish heist movie or
something like but even then it's like
we now we gotta go with this heist now
we gotta go this ice now the end it's
like the heist half the time I can't
even follow her what I do I just don't
care because I'm like we'll be following
the movie didn't turn on to me until
they got to that damn gym place casino
now I could see they're just cuz I'm
like okay at least a yeah well well
where they meet vision or whatever the
the crimson dawn guy or wake like yeah
because there's a little bit of setting
up like yeah I felt like heist movie
that came I took my watch that was like
45 minutes into this movie and I'm just
like wow 45 minutes I feel like the
movie finally kind of switched on here
and then yes the Lando scenes like or
hands-down the best in his
really weird relationship with his robot
I won't judge but we're learning things
about robots in the Star Wars universe
that must have slipped past Disney
sensei's because I'm just like wow but
but with all that said there's stuff in
this movie I thought was kind of fun
any time he does kind of mad like a
smuggler like like when he's at war and
he's sneaky and like you know yeah so
would you get there it's like you know
it's like we're gonna shoot you it's
like no I have a better idea if you used
me me out I can get you this and I can
get in there like yeah take him away and
stuff he's like don't leave without me
don't leave with that and it's like
these little scenes like that I like and
laser the connection with land Oracle
and I kinda felt like a smuggler moon
when they're playing poker and stuff
like that the shots are Kali can have
Western or film noir so I got like that
shit is cool you know the who's gonna
get out the gun further they're trying
to play up the who do you trust but they
do it so terribly God from the start
ya know like they're their moments and
as I said I don't but a lot of it goes
that way to lost some of the some of the
action is cool but so much of it it's
just like is just some of the most
piss-poor action filming I it is like
bland we're gonna shake the camera round
somebody throws a punch another jump cut
to somewhere like it I'm just like
really like this is a Star Wars movie
and like it's just this kind of bland
ass like accent Lee it I don't know I'll
say this I didn't think it was that bad
but I was getting bored of it like a lot
of the action scene as I was kind of
game time how do you get bored with an
action scene in the Star Wars movie a
good stills movie you shouldn't know
even um that should be even even the the
prequels um you know the lightsaber
fights were cool and some of the space
pals were cool say I don't like hot
racing when I'm alone yes that's true
but ya know a lot of the action due to
their crab i thought was pretty good and
i think needs the only location that
felt like a star wars location to me was
Kessel I'm just like okay feel like I'm
in a Star Wars movie again
here is that we're aliens no Kessel's um
our land own was felt pretty yeah the
exterior was just here's some more
Mountains the almighty the inside again
that's like the canteen I job yeah okay
that was fine but I I mean a bigger
vocation I was a small seemed like has
the spice mines that and that was the
only part where I'm like yeah I feel
like I'm in the star was everything else
like the opening on Corellia I'm just
like so you just found some steel mill
to shoot at and I know it sounds weird
because we complain about Oh CGI and
stuff but a chance another thing I like
how much is actually in this movie
there's a lot of stuff that's really
there and I yeah at the very least it
looks at that but robot looks like it's
really there's a middle ground you know
George Lucas shot in Tunisia
you know they they built the sets for
Bespin and this it's just I really feel
like I'm like now I'm just watching
Grand Theft Auto like the first ten
minutes of this movie like this it's
just some steel mill in LA like right up
against the water it just I'm like none
of this looks like Star Wars I mean they
try to make it look like Sarah's like
who they're building a Star Destroyer in
the background they're lifting like up
the shields and I'm like no and that's
the other thing the special effects in
this aren't really hit and miss there
are some scenes like when that when the
Falcon crash lands like that one planet
I'm just like wow that is really fakie
and their scenes were like soulless
almost being Misha pretty good no there
you can see them again there's a lot of
shadows a lot of dark and again I think
that's a problem with the two is that so
much of the shadows and everything you
know do just start to blend together
that we're gonna go to a dark brown that
first always at our solo that first solo
car chase at the very beginning it
almost looks like one of those YouTube
videos where they're inserting Star Wars
things into like a cityscape well yeah
special effects real like and some of
the effects there was like there was one
shot particular like a stormtrooper gets
on a speeder or something that was so
fake I was just like yeah that's really
just really CG yeah and I'm just like
really like money was thrown at this
like this is pretty piss-poor guys it
doesn't bother me too much
it's I don't know if this looks and
feels like a film
that was in production hell that's all I
can see yeah and I shit and I'll give us
crazy with all the various story now yet
to do this now you to do this side quest
now you do do it now those persons on
this side now this person it's like but
there's again it's if we're taught to
throw in why we're supposed to have he
has no chemistry with the love interest
so and Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
did have chemistry now we know why the
the only town he really has in this
movie again is which schooi yeah no i I
felt I watch and I felt Lando and his
robot yeah I don't know why they chose
to do that but you know they don't do
much credit to Tom above her because he
gave it a zog's like you will believe
that a man can fall in love with his
robot there was a little bit with him in
Lando but again I felt like that could
have been super solid if they spent more
time when I got it it was a Lando move
my god I got the fact that they're like
frenemies and I thought that really
worked yeah again I wanted more of them
hmm like ii like you know like he could
have just been him and Lando and Shoei
now yeah I would have really liked if
that was the movie the side characters
they're not awful they just don't they
didn't Graeme it Oh like in them in the
East Sea I don't like the music either
like it just was seriously they just
copy them pasted like the best of Star
Wars I got you know like the dude was
seeing if he could get a snippet from
every Star Wars movie and more it just
felt you know what it feels like when
you're playing like well those start old
Star Wars cd-rom games and they just
throw it yeah you've parts of the score
like ran wave it's just like that it's
like they're in an asteroid field well
we're gonna play the asteroid belt thing
from Empire it's like oh there's a Star
Destroyer welp we're gonna play the
Death Star theme for some reason I'm
like I don't know this is like da da da
and I was like well why didn't you play
the Imperial watch Oh crewman music now
remember yeah that was
the other life and they played the
entirety of my house just like with the
Empire today just playing on the desktop
radio all the time just play that music
I really just wanted like Darth Vader to
be like would you like to do war like
why you see icons be the Empire needs
you know it just I don't know it didn't
feel much like that the whole visual
style everything about it just it just
felt strangely divorced from Star Wars
I'm like I feel like I'm in someone
else's universe now if I can go quite
and broke one I didn't feel with it and
I know like rogue one's another one that
was like last Jedi are all these other
recent ones where it's just like some
people it's like hit and miss but like I
think even if you don't like work one
like it still feels like it's in the
Star Wars universe get Ben out of this I
really didn't and it's weird
again with the couple scenes I did what
with the first bid what I was liking
about it the angle I was enjoying was
that it was doing what Robin was doing
where it really feels like you're
someone walking through this universe
even though you know a lot this has had
some b-roll and if you're walking no no
they did better they were doing it and
like I said I like some of the callbacks
to you know classic war classic movies
you know and then Star Wars and stuff
like that but yeah somewhere like I said
I think as soon as it's just that the
reason for him to be doing anything
suddenly comes to him and it's like if
that to me is where they're gonna be
start sticking me with it I felt like
time and again and that war seemed
bothered me too because it was a
callbacks World War one first off why
why do we need that second it was yet in
a series of many excuses this film had
to not show us something like it's like
well we can't afford a giant planets
gave us a um fog mud there now we just
have to CGI a couple of ships in the
background we're good you don't need to
see anything I'm out ins what are gonna
more mountains here oh beach no I feel
like and then again just like they were
coming up with excuses not to show us a
big exotic locale like they didn't have
the budget or something
I like him going to well first of all I
like the famous character goes to war
something about that feels right and
they becomes a smile like he's got a
seed you know the tummies got to see the
real grueling stuff and he'll just kind
of go wherever he can to you know I'm
not saying he can't go to war I know and
I see you like so high Joe is we create
that World War 1 atmosphere especially
when you know the Empire taking over and
stuff like that I mean I don't know that
felt that felt right somehow because I
think of the dogfights that they have in
the earth Star Wars movies there's
already Campbell World War 1 feel to it
but we never seemed like kind of with
the exception of Empire Strikes Back we
never really see them like in the
trenches and even then that was kind of
the winter trenches that they have with
Hoth so I like the idea that they kind
of went that angle like I don't know it
felt right to me that kind of felt like
that would you know I don't even when
they took off like you still didn't see
anything it's like you see some laser
blasts through the clouds and I'm just
like they really don't want to show us
anything it is where no you brought up
you said every time the Millennium
Falcon which it is nice to see it like
clean and nice that was really cool I
know like it right they never show them
like taking off like that should be a
big things that they're gonna just go up
top something turns it takes off and
it's just like when it takes off it's
just already in the air I know they they
literally like literally Woody
Harrelson's like you better buckle up
kid and Han just like sits down next
thing you know we're like off planet
like literally in the sky like bro like
if there's no scene of it taking off or
like oh this is a big moment and there's
multiple moments like that where it's
just like I would have milked that for
all it's worth
do you like the stuff because it's the
first time he's in this thing yeah you
should kind of have that feeling you
don't need to go batshit with the deal
on my hand it is when he went into
hyperspace
Rob if they have to milk other things
like Chewie playing chess or Han Solo
say Chewbacca
that's long I'm gonna have to give you a
nickname it's like we don't but stuff
but here's the thing
stuff like him playing cards with Lando
and seeing how he does make it out of
the Kessel run and some of these other
scenes like I think do work so I mean
with me I'm Lando
Lando's worker its this is a caricature
like a spoof of Lando almost
he was almost trying to juggle a couple
but but it kind of reddish you're nice
like by the time you get to Lando an
empire you feel like he's got
responsibilities and this is Ned when
you look at him here it's just like yeah
I could kind of see him being that full
of himself like wears a cape like that I
mean like I feel that's my Herod series
got like a collection of capes yeah and
he kind of does like a blog telling the
stories and everything I'm like
graphically known okay cuz I'm with you
at first I was like that's a little
weird and then the more I thought about
like no this makes sense like that this
really does fit so yeah middle of the
road I like kind of the the first third
the first half more that I I like I like
twin middle part and the second half
best with the first 45 minutes just
being like oh my god like yeah I'm like
the Tola I liked it when was dark which
which is what I thought that was tough
overall of rogue one but I felt Rowan
was a much better movie than this and
even if you don't like rogue one I think
it was better shot than this I think it
took more risks than this I think you
couldn't predict where it was going
quite as much because they're not they
were completely original characters but
you know spark I thought it was a more
colorful movie I thought uh Noma I
thought the action was better on every
single level rogue one is better than
this movie um the one thing you know
that I think is is really true is that
you say it's not taking any risks it's a
very safe Star Wars movie and that's why
you gotta belong with the lego yeah all
the characters of all the films about
the character that should take risks
Hanzo The Skeptical the the antihero the
guy who goes back and forth I mean
before you know guy from the beginning
go hey I'm out of your time yeah
like he has to actually say I'm not a
good guy like and it's sort of script
where they just they tell you everything
there's like no room to read it into
Moses like literally is like I'm saying
you're a good guy I'm saying I'm not a
good guy well you really are well okay
if you think so guess I'm gonna be a
good guy eventually I think you'll join
our rebellion don't count on it because
he's my Butler I won't say this that may
be one of the only scenes because his
smile really was Harrison Ford that may
be one of the only times where I thought
it kind of worked because I'm just like
yeah I could see him saying that like at
this point he's like don't think so kid
I love this reactions it's very much
like shake is it like mmm-hmm like that
happening I think I I kind of like that
but yeah there's a ton of scenes like I
could see how you would not like that I
feel like there was enough kind of cool
stuff in it and stuff that I'm like okay
I'm glad I saw that in Anaheim so little
story but yeah I'm very in the middle
there's so many things that kind of
don't work or bland and you know like
all for any fans I'm just very very in
the middle when I was a kid and I mean
like really like seven or eight like
this has been the eighties like there
was like I swear to God there was a han
Solo book they had a collective like Han
Solo stories hmm and I felt like those
were kind of cooler than this like where
we haven't read it since the mid or late
80s but and I swear they went to Kessel
I thought - they went to the Kessel
mines like I know if they're pulling any
of it from this but like I haven't read
it and so long as everybody who correct
me cuz but but I feel like those books
which are now non-canon I don't know if
Emma was ever cannon anyway but I know I
just felt like those somehow captured
something kind of like scoundrelly about
it it's just I to me this is a it exists
i I don't
apart from the fact how bland it looks I
don't hate it but it's very much just
like yeah I saw this movie once I don't
hate it it got a few good laughs out of
me but I'm never gonna think about this
movie again I'm definitely probably I
doubt I'm never gonna buy it
unless I really just just like want the
Lando scenes or something I don't go
like c-plus as a grade if I were to hmm
yeah I don't know that that's me it's a
little it's just very I've like I've
seen a lot worse I've seen a lot better
yeah so it's uh it probably gave me
exactly what I was expecting the more I
think about it I like going in like I
said it was win me over a little bit in
some scenes I'm like yeah pretty much
what I thought I was gonna get so it's
uh it's kind of like Star Wars fan
fiction you know if that's just but
there's a lot of people that like this
nothing I can tell they're people
they're like okay the Lando robot scenes
were so okay yeah no boy no I mean like
you know I feel like she would have
taken more risks
honestly like fan fiction you can get
pretty bad shit and I'm just like yeah
this this literally felt like a studio
product like like I thought rogue one
like it give the fans what role kingpin
yeah rogue one had a person this kind of
stuff Brooklyn a person whether you like
last Jedi or not oh give two shits but
it's just like that had a personality
like force awakens personality overall
but I could see how people want to argue
it didn't but if you think something
like force awakens an emperor has is
just playing it's a free hand like
that's all this movie is to me force
awakens in a sense of you yeah it's a
this is a corporate product like it's in
a deals very formative and bland as you
can get and just like well the fans want
to see this I guess and like oh oh you
might be taking risks better fire the
Lego guys behind originally and bring
around Hardin because that slowly does
post-2000 this bland stuff so yeah
they're yeah we got plane to talk about
most whaler corners oh I definitely join
us there yeah as I said I'm under the
weather so if you like the movie great
maybe I'm just being a grump mixture
where is it not
like a light heart so your Whitney
Morris check not my soul now I've never
I did I don't know what you would have
to take to basically make me like was
last Jedi haters but like I I don't
think that's good I love Star Wars I
still do so bad in happening with maybe
if you made nothing but films like this
for the next 20 years like now they
might be I don't know maybe if the next
eight films are exact like this is
really a duplicate where's your button
so I like Star Wars even the prequels I
mean I can get through cific No
the only one I cannot possibly sit
through attack of the clones is a
tagging function I connect to now I can
actually get through Phantom Menace yeah
there's a bit of that sort of baggy it's
strangely nostalgic it takes me back to
1999 yeah but but attack of the clones
is only one day I will not sit through
that I get five minutes an anthem at
least is kind of so sad you can laugh at
it like I have it close it's like ultra
attack all right attack of the clones is
garbage with some pretty special effects
that's it so there you go bad as our
thoughts on so long so got to give you a
nickname
how about Fido oh all right here chew on
this
you